[Music]
[Music]
hey
y'all happy st patrick's day i know
we're already starting
and i didn't realize i accidentally wore
something green today
and something booze related i didn't
even mean to do that because i totally
forgot it was st patrick's day when i
was getting dressed
and i promise but i won't get pinched at
least
no one's around to pinch me anyway if
you pinch me i'll hit you
[Laughter]
the boy walker's down there at some of
one of these pubs dressed up in his down
kilt and [ __ ] eating
drinking [ __ ] [ __ ] funny
where's he at what's that one place
that's across from my bar lizzy
mccormick lizzie mcguire something like
that i've been in there a couple times
it didn't look like it though because
that place is like super dark and i
think that's just a bar i don't even
know if you can get food in there maybe
you can
but uh yeah mango says is it saint
patty's day yeah it is it's march 17th
like i said i forgot
we don't have any green beer or anything
however tom did get a shamrock shake the
other day
oh that was a long time ago that was
like last week yeah
oh man they got shamrock shakes i said
i'm getting that [ __ ] it's too many
calories and then it comes time to order
us let's give it a say
it was good man i forgot how good those
things were okay
that mint flavor yeah it's really weird
because you think i'd be super into that
but like
when i always when i was growing up i'd
be like i don't know it seems kind of
gross but then
i don't know when i have a sip of it it
seems really good yeah
i don't know what that is it's not ice
cream i think it's little cute little
bits of gelatin or something
well i think that it in there well maybe
frozen gelatin maybe
well they're milkshakes none of them are
ice cream yeah there's nothing in that
they're just they're powdered
it's like powdered milk and like you
just put it in the machine i bet you
it's a little tiny
because there's some kind of grit in
there trying to fool you into it
into it being ice or ice cream that's
not what that is
it's like fake that is yeah that's
that's like
probably pieces of bugs you know how
they take it
you know they take the [ __ ] beetle
carapace and make the [ __ ]
fake seeds for [ __ ] strawberry seeds
well they call this [ __ ]
yeah i know what you're talking yeah
it's not it's not they make a lot of
stuff out of those it won't hurt you
it's just i mean you know it's just
gross if you think about it yeah
but you know bug carapace yeah yeah
i don't well i told you i read a whole
book about that um
that one beetle that they made that red
dye out of that was like really popular
in the [ __ ] middle ages and whatnot
yeah and how there was like a huge
economy
in that in those particular beetles
because they made this really bright uh
this really really nice red diet but the
the book was called uh a perfect red but
i don't remember who
uh wrote it but it was like super
fascinating but yeah like
i don't know it's it's not like steak
and shake
they actually make actual shakes with
ice cream but uh
mcdonald's never have you know what i
mean yeah they're still okay
every now and then although i if i'm
gonna have something like that i'd
rather go to wendy's and get a frosty to
be honest with you and
some french fries in it people are still
showing up it's still early
you guys got your drinks better
so we saw this thing uh last night it
was a
program on the mormon church yeah murder
among the mormons
yeah they got it on netflix yeah it's
new
yeah it's like a mini series i knew a
little bit
about this case but i didn't know a lot
of the details about it so i kind of
knew where it was going but not exactly
i think during the third one i think i
dozed off a little bit because i was
like super super sleepy
but um yeah so if you don't know this
happened back in the 80s right it was
like mid 80s i think it was 1985.
and there's this dude
named mark hoffman who he's still alive
i think he's in prison
and he was well i'm getting ahead of
myself a little bit but
there was a kind of a rash is three
bombings a rash i guess you could call
it that
so it was three bombings in salt lake
city uh they were
mail bombs yeah they were like in
packages and
these two guys got blown up well it was
actually the this one guy got blown up
by a
by a male bomb and then a woman got
blown up but they think that the bomb
was
meant for her husband and then like this
dude named mark hoffman got blown up
like with a car bomb but he didn't die
and then as they go on with the
investigation because they're all
mormons like i said because it's salt
lake city
and they're talking about um
mark hoffman being this big like back in
the 80s he was kind of like
uh the go-to guy like if you wanted
some mormon artifact like historical
artifacts like documents and stuff
because i guess there's a big thing um
in mormonism where
they really really like to have all of
these documents you know like the joseph
smith wrote and like all these original
documents from like when the religion
was founded
well i think that's why i think maybe
they're a little insecure about how like
how
how young the religion is so they're
just always kind of like they i think
they just like to
kind of establish a history or whatever
well they want to prove that it happens
yeah and then they want it they want to
be able to support
you know the teachings of the church
they want to say hey this is all real we
really did talk to you know
he really did talk to the angel moroni
we got it written right here
it's because he wrote about it it proves
that it happened
which is a religious thinking a lot of
religions do that
this because it's written it's it was
done well [ __ ] i can write down all
right i can write down all kind of
[ __ ] it's just like
it's just like christian and islamic
church history like there's christian
church history has to
to uh tertullian and all these other
[ __ ] early church fathers doing
walking around all over europe forming
the the church and talking to this king
and that emperor
man one dude didn't do all that [ __ ]
they made all that church history up
because they were insecure because
christianity appeared out of nowhere
as far as you know what i mean it didn't
it didn't have a written history
which that really boggles people on
people's minds
and i believe islam is the same way i
think it was made up out of whole cloth
well yeah i mean uh all religions and
we've kind of talked about this before
they're just kind of like an
amalgamation of [ __ ] that came before
you know uh
stories of people told one another
folklore um
all that kind of crap but like the funny
thing about this was that
mark uh hoffman he kind of first came to
prominence because of that
uh what they call the white salamander
letter yeah
and the funny thing about this it's just
like
i mean spoiler alert it's a forgery but
had it even had it been
real it really really made me laugh
that the reason that this letter was so
massively controversial like within the
mormon church
was that essentially the letter said
that joseph smith hadn't been led to the
golden plates
by the angel moroni but rather by a
white salamander yeah
some satanic spin to it doesn't it well
more of like a folk magic or an occult
kind of so that's what they were
offended about
but i'm sitting there going you mean to
tell me that even if this letter was
real which it wasn't
you mean to tell me that grown-ass men
are arguing over whether a dude
got information from a celestial angel
or a magic amphibian
yeah seriously you guys are having
meetings about that
you are grown-ass people yeah holy [ __ ]
but yeah so oh
another thing i learned too from this uh
from this mini series
that i did not know before that i'm kind
of delighted about is that the mormons
have their own i don't know if they
still have it have their own
specific mormon specific version of
trivial pursuit
and it's called celestial pursuit yeah
and the box kind of looks the same and
the board kind of looks the same
i guess they had i don't know if they
had to change it a little bit because i
don't know if it's like endorsed by
whoever makes trivial pursuit because i
know they have different versions of
trivial pursuit like that's not that
weird but i don't know if the
mormon one is like endorsed by that
company but i was just like well it was
just like an offhand thing that they
mentioned and i'm like
that's so funny i don't know that just
like really made me laugh and i don't
know why that was like a big takeaway
church latter day saints is a trip
it's it's it's christianity part two
but even more american electric booklet
yeah and
uh when you look at the motif and the
style of all the writings and all the
architecture and everything
it's masonic it's like something that
should be
you know in washington dc or you know
the [ __ ]
the back of the dollar bill that's what
it looks like everything looks like it
should be some kind of
something out of the us government you
know and it's just because they
it's illuminati it was yeah
and i think it's because it came from
the 1800s and uh
in the 1800s that motif was real
respected you know it was very austere
looking and so uh and i think they were
kind of
envious of masonic lodges and
masonic temples and they wanted their
[ __ ] to look like that
well they want some secret society
action going man
i think they also kind of wanted to be
able to kind of write them into masonic
lore
yeah interesting we're like masons
that's what they're saying yeah we're
cool we
we built the country yeah i can't see
that that's what it is
we're more powerful than we actually are
that's what they're saying
always a good uh always a good look for
like if you start trying to start a new
religion yeah you know what i mean we're
we're uh we're part of the masons and we
bought we built the pyramids and the and
and the the american government you know
that's that's what
that's how they're trying to write
themselves in this is all
you know what's funny is i saw fanboy
[ __ ] back in the day
people kind of had this in in thank you
zach
my birthday is on the 19th happy
birthday early birthday
turns out i share it with glenn close uh
harvey weinstein i guess
and the head of a concentration camp
whose name i forget yay me
[Laughter]
the um that's some kind of shitty people
the one glenn close is cool but other
than that
funny thing about religion is that uh
you know it was its own genre
you know religious you know religious
mythology the religious [ __ ]
genre but today you see it's a lot like
comic books and other kind of fanboy
stuff they do a lot of [ __ ] they have an
extended universe
there's an extended universe there's all
kinds of it's that same mentality
there's spin-offs there's all kinds of
stuff and uh
kind of reboots and rip-offs and uh
people trying to
merge one universe into the other
universe so you so your religion looks
bigger
because you're you know you've written
it in a way where it's kind of absorbed
a sister religion into it so therefore
you can claim authority over that one
which is what what what the muslims were
doing they were claiming authority over
all of christianity
doing what they did they didn't make
something brand new it's an extension
well it's the same mentality of like
let's just like remake a movie that
everybody knows it's like
an intellectual property that everyone's
going to recognize you'd be like
well it's like that but it's new and
improved see right
you know that's a much easier sell than
here's this thing that you've never
heard of before they also
um they also did a lot of stuff um
adopted a lot of stuff from islam into
it which they thought were improvements
celestial wives and this and that and
their own courts
and uh even in the day of joseph smith
he was being called the american
muhammad and he liked that term
you know because he was
he's trying to create a narrative very
much like muhammad
if there was a mohammed yeah i doubt i
don't think there was
there's a lot of suspicious stuff in in
history about islam
same thing with christianity
christianity appears in the 3rd
century pretty much out of nowhere with
the roman government saying it's their
official religion
and then get get together compiling all
the christian beliefs
we're going to make a new testament so
christianity predates the new testament
by long by hundreds of years
yeah an unknown religion pretty much uh
it was it did not take over the empire
uh uh you know um by word of mouth and
all this
and because the the the romans were
feeding christians to the lions and
that's all [ __ ] not
none of that's in history it's just in
christian mythology
uh it appears out of nowhere in the
third century
when rome adopts it as a as an official
religion of the empire and it was not
real well codified it was just kind of a
general
thing we're christian whatever that is
that's how it [ __ ] appears yeah awful
you know no
church history none of that all that
stuff came hundreds of years later when
they're trying to explain
how it became uh
uh a religion which tells you that there
wasn't anything to it
yeah the wall that was a retcon yeah
that's what they would call that right
now
[Laughter]
well yeah you mentioned and they were
very the early christians you know what
i mean you're talking about in the fifth
sixth seventh eighth century
were real kinda
um uh [ __ ] insecure about the fact
that josephus made no mention of
christianity
and joe he jose josephus had a it was an
ancient roman historian he was a jewish
roman historian
and he wrote a history book called the
antiquities of the jews or the history
of the jews
and there's no and he's writing it
around the time jesus would have been
around you know
he'd have been crucified maybe you know
10 years prior or something
there's no mention of any of that and
that really caused a lot of sleepless
nights they had to put some
they had to put some [ __ ] in there later
yeah a couple hundred years later 400
years later they actually put it in
there
that yes well maybe he just forgot to
mention it yeah he forgot to mention
this
that's got it this isn't right he forgot
to mention jesus
jose josephus would have said this and
they put a whole [ __ ] paragraph in
there and it's not in the older versions
so you know they added it yeah that they
added that [ __ ] later
but yeah so the funny thing about this
well it's not funny because like
people died and [ __ ] but so this guy
who as i said spoiler alert was like a
master forger i will give him that i
mean he's a piece of [ __ ]
probably listening to his interviews and
like the way he acted and stuff
probably a psychopath um because he
seemed to like give zero shits about
anybody
uh and kind of thought he was better
than everybody yeah i just decided that
you know someone had to die he just kind
of says [ __ ] like that
yeah so he had been forging all this
stuff
it's weird because he was making money
by i mean basically like he got in with
all the other
uh you know kind of collectors and you
know uh
document dealers and whatever not just
mormon stuff but you know it was mostly
mormon stuff because they were kind of
looking for things
and so he got in with that crowd and
he'd be talking to somebody and you know
somebody be like oh man i really wish
that i had
you know xyz like this letter or
whatever or a letter from
joseph smith's wife or something like
that and then coincidentally
you know a month or two later look what
i found when i was
in this you know old book shop in london
i came across this letter and i
remembered that you said something about
it
so he did this like so many times that
i'm surprised nobody said
are you just making this [ __ ] yourself
cause it seems like you're just making
the [ __ ] yourself
because he was making the [ __ ] himself
um so yeah so this the white salamander
letter
that was fake he faked a lot of mormon
[ __ ] and he faked a lot of
like americana [ __ ] like he faked like
some george washington stuff betsy ross
like letters from that
and he was a master he was yeah i will
say that he's a piece of [ __ ] but
he was really really good at it they
said that it was hard to detect his
fakes i mean they were
i mean even the fbi they had like well
the mormon church they looked into it of
course they're going to say yes it's
real but you know what i mean
they had the fbi look into it they've
been and it was like really really
difficult
for them to um kind of pin them up on
anything because it really does seem
like
i don't know i mean this guy sucks
because he killed people because i think
what was happening was that
he um i think he thought that he was
going to be exposed at some point
because it was this really big deal that
he was going through that wasn't
anything to do with uh
with mormon stuff but it was to do with
uh
a piece of paper that was supposedly the
first thing that was like printed
in the united states like you know in
the early days of the united states
and um and he had made that as well and
he was gonna sell it for like
1.5 million or something but he thought
that he was gonna get busted
so he blew up his
partner or like one of the other
collectors like he sent like a
letter bomb to him and blew the dude up
and then he
sent another letter bomb like a the same
day or the next day
to another dude but his wife opened it
and it killed her
it didn't kill the guy and then this
crazy [ __ ]
i guess to allay suspicion from himself
blew himself up in his own car
and he was hurt like i think like some
of his fingers were blown off and he was
all [ __ ] up and everything
he didn't die but i'm like that's crazy
[ __ ]
that is crazy [ __ ] yeah like so they so
no one's suspected because they just
thought he was a victim so like oh my
god he blew up too and if you want to go
to jail
i get well that's where he ended up yeah
um
but yeah so when they finally caught him
they actually caught him
when they looked through his [ __ ] um you
know his house and they found like a
receipt
for some kind of printing plates that he
had ordered
um for you know something he had done
like that mormon money or whatever like
he
treated a lot in that kind of stuff so
he had ordered a plate for that
somewhere but he had used a fake name
but i guess you know they they cut they
got him on it somehow like they found
some other document that had the same
fake name on it and blah blah
it's like you know if you watch it
you'll see what i'm talking about but so
they finally like
caught him on that and once they caught
him he pretty much just gave everything
up and he was
if you listen to him his interviews
about it he's just so [ __ ] cold about
it
like yeah i just thought i was gonna get
in trouble so i just knew these people
had to die so he just started blowing
people up what the [ __ ] man
but i mean other than that like i kind
of have
i've always been fascinated by like art
thieves and art forgers because it
really
seems like um it's it's really like not
it's not an easy way to make money i
mean particularly art forgery because
that [ __ ] is really really difficult you
have to get every single thing exactly
right
because experts at this point there's
been so many forgeries that they pretty
much know what to look for
so the fact that he was making this
stuff i mean you really have to like go
get paper from that time for you can't
have anything that's like anachronistic
like in any way like the ink or what
or you know the language that you use
the type of pen
you use all this other kind of [ __ ] like
they know exactly what to look for
he they said that he had even started
forging [ __ ]
when he was like a teenager he was
forging coins
you know what i mean like really
valuable coins and i'm like
i mean he had a calling i guess
but it's i don't know it's a [ __ ] up
story man but like i said it's only
three episodes
but yeah so i've always been fascinated
by art forgers
if you um ever look up maybe i want to
do a show about this guy one of these
days
there was a dude named han van meegeren
it was like early 20th century early to
mid 20th century
and he was a very famous art forger and
i've read a couple books about him and i
just love
all the details about um
about how he made things look old he
mostly
i think he did a couple other ones as
well but i think he mostly forged
uh vermeers and he actually ended up
selling a couple of them to the nazis
like the nazis fell for it because you
know how they were always like buying up
art and stuff
and he managed to like make quite a bit
of money like going hey it's a vermeer
that i found in some attic somewhere and
they were like get out of here and they
bought it
um he was one of the people that
famously he got caught and nobody
believed that he had painted the [ __ ]
so he painted it in the
courtroom you know what i mean although
i will say that some of the
some of the forgeries that he did i
think he got kind of lazy like toward
the end because some of the
ones later because i've seen like
vermeers like in real life
and um they have this really interesting
like
almost like 3d kind of quality and a
couple of his early ones are like that
but then like
han van meeran's like later forgeries
just seemed like they were all slapdash
and half-assed
i think he got to a point where he's
like you know people will buy these
anyway so why kill myself like trying to
make it super
super awesome looking because it's like
no one's really gonna question it
because i think when he was starting out
like he wanted to make sure everything
was
was correct so he would get away with it
but after a while he was like they're
not even checking so why the hell should
i
expend all this effort like trying to
make it really good
but he's like a fascinating dude and one
of these days
like i said i've read a couple books
about him it was a while back but i'd
like to do a show about him one of these
days because i'm
i don't know i'm just like really really
interested in art forgery and also in
the
kind of technical aspects of how you
make things look old and [ __ ] like that
you know yeah yeah
see um somebody was in there saying that
uh what is christianity but just uh
a spin-off of uh judaism
that's only partially true in a way the
relationship evidently between judaism
and
christianity is awful strange um
okay here's a good example the roman
roman description of what
of judaism doesn't doesn't resemble
anything
like modern judaism at all i mean they
were worse they they were using asherah
poles
and what they're describing is uh
something kind of like the greek
pantheon
you know a father of the gods and then
all his sons and demigods
it was just kind of like a started off
as like a a redneck
version of the greek religion you know
the gods on mount olympus it was that
but this was like
you know country people you know no no
their version of it these were the
pantheon in the trailer park
and evidently there was like uh child
sacrifice going on you know the people
that words of molech were
evidently throwing their little children
into the furnaces you know into a
furnace and other people were
sacrificing the firstborn and all that
evidently they found a bunch of clay
pots with little
babies that had been sacrificed and um
that's not modern judaism but that's
well
obviously yeah so then you had the
septugen which was kind of like the uh
the greek version of the old testament
and uh that's that's about the same age
as the new testament
uh the the the one that's uh tacked on
to the bible
and that seems to be been what the jews
used
um now it doesn't necessarily mean that
the religion that they had
was the same though uh modern judaism
seems to
be medieval from the medieval period so
it's not that old
but modern christianity is about from
the medieval period too
so by rights in some ways you could say
that judaism and
and christianity are about the same age
because they've been rebooted over and
over again
well i feel like they're still getting
rebooted it's not it's not
that well that's the thing about human
history you never get to a point where
like well we're done
yeah it's like we figured that's that's
just that doesn't happen
[ __ ] like keeps changing all the time
you know what i mean so it's still
you know [ __ ] religions are still
evolving nowadays yeah i think they were
influencing each other kind of side by
side for you know
centuries yeah that actually does make
sense i mean
you know like i said we've had uh you
know dr price on the show a couple of
times and
he's always like really interesting to
listen to because i'm always like i said
i'm just like fascinated by
uh the history of religion and like
mythology and where
the where all the ideas for the [ __ ]
come from like where all the stories
came from why they were codified in a
particular way
um you know it's just all that's like
really really interesting to me
now the if i remember correctly it was
somewhere in the pauline epistles i mean
it's misquoting
it's misquoting uh jewish scripture
evidently misquoting it on purpose to
try to
make jesus a little bit more um
uh jewish you know i'm talking about to
make it look like
he was foretold you know what i mean in
jewish scriptures you know what i mean
having to do with you know uh
with uh what do you call them messiahs
and everything but it's an
obvious misquote of it you know jewish
scholars can go in there and go
no that's not what the original
scripture actually said they're
misquoting it
well you have to pre-exist in order to
misquote
so christianity is
playing off of judaism it's a sect of
judaism if you ask me
yeah in the same way that you know the
mormonism is a sect of christianity it
it's the same religion it's just a
part two you know it's a sequel
yeah yeah i don't know i've just always
been
we one of these days we're gonna do a
show about the mormons in general
because like i said this
the show that they that they had on
netflix it's not about mormonism
as a whole it was just about this one
particular incident and about this one
particular guy
and it goes a little bit you know it
doesn't go a lot into what they actually
believe or anything like that it's
mostly just about this one guy and his
forgeries and
they only go as much into their beliefs
as needed
to say why this particular document
would have been important
and stuff like that but i don't know
it's like
all this kind of stuff um you know seth
is saying i just find all religion
cuckoo it is
um it had a it made a lot more sense
back in those days yeah a lot of the
context has been lost
i think um because that that's one thing
there were clubs to go along with it
yeah night clubs basically you went to
work
you got high like i said what else drank
and dance you know i mean
they were put on a big show it was a
nightclub scene really
that's what you would recognize it as
because here
because here's what i found really
interesting about like for example the
white salamander letter
um even though it was a fake there had
to be some reason
why he faked it to say that particular
thing
like why you want to spice it up well i
know but why a white salamander
specifically was that something that had
to do with
the time period like i know that it's he
was kind of met i remember not
they didn't mention it in that program
but i remember in another program it was
mentioned
that he used to like to [ __ ] riff on
the mormons a lot and yeah
and he wanted the mormons to suspect
that their religion had more of a cult
beginnings that it was more of an occult
yeah
i got that but i didn't really
understand why necessarily a white
salamander in particular
would get that across in the way that
some like a toad
like something that's not that a witch
would be that's what i'm saying but
well yeah but i i was saying more like a
thing more like a toad or like a black
cat or something
that's what i would think white
salamander i didn't realize that that
was like
necessarily a specific occult sim
symbol or to be original or like a
familiar
in the sense that a black cat or a toad
or something like that is more
understood well they might
they might reject a black cat or
rejected because that'd be like two of
them oh that's too obvious right
that's a little more ambiguous you know
what i mean they might accept that
which they did they went oh yeah that
that that may be true
you know he had a good gig he knew that
he knew he knew that the mormons would
pretty much accept anything
he also knew that they were suspicious
of their own religion
even if they wouldn't admit it they
wouldn't admit it but they were
suspicious of it yeah
that's still it didn't want the reason
why they bought the white salamander
letter is they wanted to hide it
yeah they wanted people to know that
that was a white salamander
no it was an angel shut up yeah they
were gonna hide it they were gonna bury
that
yeah well a lot of the stuff that they
bought was stuff that they were planning
on burying
it was stuff that was uncomfortable so
buying it would get it out of
circulation
yeah even though later like the
president of the mormon church came out
and said we totally didn't even
uh offer to buy that he said that he was
going to like give it to our museum but
we wouldn't believe it
we totally were not going to suppress it
or anything by any strategy
no no of course not i don't believe
those dudes
[Laughter]
oracle says jenny want a true crime book
about the case yeah i would
i would actually love that to be to be
honest with you that sounds like super
that sounds really fascinating
stop prop says having grown up in
palmyra palmyra
i don't know how to pronounce that new
york mormons are no less insane
than scientologists joseph smith started
his madness there yeah that's right well
they were i think they were a lot alike
they well they are there's a lot of
there's a lot of similarities
yeah i'm sure lrh looked at at mormonism
to see how it started
because he wanted to start a religion so
he would have studied
how they were starting well yeah if he
was smart yeah that's what you do
you study other successful religions and
see what they did
try to figure out what it was that they
did that made them so successful
i mean you know it's it's hard to do i
guess it's kind of hard to do one
um you know on purpose because there has
to be
you know there's a lot of factors that i
guess you can't control because people
start cults all the time and
like you know most of them don't catch
on obviously the whole thing about
joseph smith the [ __ ]
the the magic glasses and the tablets
and talking to the [ __ ] angels and
the magic panties and the magic
panties no yeah yeah he's
doing this from behind a [ __ ] silk
shroud and [ __ ] dictating
dictating what the celestial [ __ ]
forces are telling
that's exact same thing lrh did he just
call himself source
the source same thing i mean i love
i love joseph smith comes out with a
story like hey guys
this angel came to me in the woods and
told me
that i could find these gold plates and
i wrote down what they said on them
but nobody can see them and everyone was
just like oh okay i suppose so
yeah you couldn't get away with that
[ __ ] nowadays let me see the plates
[ __ ]
let's see i'm coughing you could get
away with it today don't ever believe
that you couldn't do it
well yeah it's probably look at what
they you know look at what l ron hubbard
did and
yeah you can get people to believe just
all kinds of crazy
you just gotta go about it in the right
way you have to select the right kind of
person and have to be groomed the right
way
and you can get people to believe
anything
i think scientology because we've talked
about this before i think scientology
was so successful because
it sort of eased you in you know like
the frog in boiling water
it's like you know when you first start
it just sounds like some self-help [ __ ]
yeah and it's just like oh this actually
is helping it's helping me communicate
better because there's nothing
that weird it's you know religion is
kind of like
and it's indoctrination it's mind
control basically you know and it's done
like any other form of propaganda
you just study how propaganda works
and that's how religion works same way
you can get anybody to believe anything
pretty much if you're uh if you're
determined yep because every
all you have to tell them is that uh
well this is for the betterment of
mankind and this
this makes everybody better and [ __ ]
you know this is the right thing to do
and you'll do it well the thing too is
that
a lot of stuff about religions is stuff
that can't be
proven either way you know because like
the whole christianity thing oh you get
a heaven after you die well no we could
prove that obviously
because no one has come back and like
reported on it
so you can get away with a lot of [ __ ]
like that because no one's going to call
you
on your line there's whole books written
on propaganda and how to you know mass
mind control you know and just
if you control the narrative and you
control all the media outlets you can
you can you can spin in any narrative
you want and and it's
and i'm not just bagging on the united
states the united states does it
but so do all the other countries you
can go to iran and
if you watch their television their
their take on reality is totally
different than ours
china's take on the outside world is
totally different than ours
you know um people believe what they're
told in general
you know there's always a certain amount
of people that just don't believe what
they're told
and a certain amount of people that are
just
i was just kind of genetically pre
predisposed to say no i just say no
to [ __ ] if you're telling if you're it
doesn't matter if
if you're trying to get me to believe it
or try to get me to do it
my natural tendency will be to say no
i'm just resistant that way well yeah i
don't really like it either and
especially if somebody's like trying to
tell me a tale if you want something
from yeah and i'm just kind of like yeah
so there's a reason why they're telling
you this who is it benefiting and does
it benefit me
and they're gonna say no it benefits the
world i'm like get the [ __ ] out of here
what it really then when they tell you
that it's benefiting
their bottom line for that quarter
that's all it is they're trying to make
some some kind of bonus there's they're
doing the same thing scientology does
well yeah they're just trying to get a
new recruit
that's what they're doing i mean you
know
like i said i'm sure like a lot of
people actually do genuinely believe it
you know i'm not [ __ ] all those
people but
i you know the the kind of this lies are
a pious lie
the person who's lying to you actually
believes these lies
they don't know it's a lie yeah it's
called a pious lie
and a lot of religions involves pious
lying they're lying
but well they either don't know that
they're lying because they have
religious beliefs or they're lying to
you telling you a little white line
to try to [ __ ] save your soul yeah
because they think it's for the greater
the greater good there's a couple
different ways that and this
extends to everything including business
you know the sales campaign is nothing
but just the propaganda
campaign lying to you about how this
product well it's just a sales pitch
just like anything else
and i mean you know anyone's in sales or
marketing or anything like that
it's just kind of the way what they
always tell you to do is
just you have to explain to people how
your
product your widget whatever makes their
lives better makes them
cooler or makes things easier for them
or something like that you have to
you know you have to give people some
kind of value and i think the same thing
applies to religions you have to appeal
to people's
you know sense of you know what is this
going to do for you
necessarily well like i said i think
that's why christianity [ __ ] like that
was real successful because they'll be
like well
your life's shitty now um you know
especially in the middle ages this would
have worked because like a lot of
people's lives were horribly shitty and
really short and diseased and whatnot
they're just like yeah it's shitty now
but that just means that you'll have
this
way better life like after you die it's
like i said
you know you can't prove yeah prove that
that that's
and then true or false and how do you
prove that one religion has a monopoly
over getting you into heaven
versus another one because they're all
claiming that that they're going to get
you into heaven
there's no way to prove any of that
we'll see and that's why i mean i think
that's why i
just became an atheist when i was a kid
because i was just like yeah but what if
you picked the wrong one
they're saying it's fantastic
well here's the thing you know i'm not
big into these religions and everything
but i believe that there's an afterlife
you know now is there a god there might
be something like a god but
let's let's go ahead and let's go ahead
and analyze based upon what these
scriptures are saying what god is
they're saying he walks around in a
garden okay
then he creates people that he talks
uh you can't look at him it'll kill you
um that he has a breath and a voice
they're saying he's a big man so what
they're talking about
is they're talking about zeus yeah
that's exactly what they're talking
that's what i always picture a giant man
big zeus man right that's what they're
talking about walking around breathing
on people
yeah and glowing at people so it's not
oh sorry killed you yeah no you looked
at me and you died
do you have to like do you have to like
wear the special sunglasses like when
you look at an eclipse i guess
and then there's the god sunglasses
angels of the lord can appear like
burning bushes and an angel of the lord
is like an avatar of the lord
because you can't look at him so it's an
image of
god not actual god so there's a bunch of
stuff that
you know but that's just that's just
that's the genre
yeah that's the genre of this type of
literature
but the literature is describing a giant
man
boring yeah i mean hands and feet and
his face and his eyes
see this is why when i was a kid i was
just i wasn't i wasn't raised or
religious but it's like to me the bible
story seemed either real [ __ ] up like
the abraham and isaac thing i was like
oh that's [ __ ] up
but um that made a lot of sense though
well i know but i'm just we're
sacrificing kids but as a kid i thought
that was really [ __ ] up
and then also seemed kind of boring
because i was like really into like
greek mythology man i'm like they got
like big monsters and like [ __ ]
yeah women with snakes for hair and [ __ ]
that's way more red well that's in there
tiamat yeah that sort of uh the dragon
is mentioned there's a tmi
you know being thrown at tiamats thrown
into the lake of fire
um leviathan which is another
thing that was kind of like tmr some
people are saying well it's a way it's a
whale
now leviathan was a god it was a
it's a seamoth this is a dragon yeah sea
dragon yeah
but um no they're not talking about
universal a universal star wars type god
you know what i mean
that's invisible and everywhere at once
and doing the
that's not really what they're talking
about um now by the time you get into
the
new testament it's kind of turned into
something like that
but by this time christianity has become
excuse me
judaism is becoming very very roman
see the romans copied all these
religions because rome was a place of
immigration well it's easier to make in
your own from scratch i mean
well that's not what was happening i
know i'm just making a joke
what was happening was is that people
from the middle east were moving in
into the roman empire and bringing their
religions with them
you had uh people who were egypt people
who believed in the egyptian religion
they came in
they get that rebooted into the cult of
isis
you have people from persia move in
and they brought mithraism with them and
they rebooted that into the cult of
mithras
then you had jews moving in and they
rebooted that into christianity
it's just a it's just a christianity is
a roman
copy a roman reboot of judaism
and it's because if you actually
if you actually look at those foreign
religions
what they were like they would have been
unacceptable in roman society
so they moved into rome and within a few
generations the people who inherited
those religions
made them more roman so they could fit
in
you know you weren't going to sacrifice
some kids or you know some of them got
banned yeah let's not do that they
weren't going to do that in rome it was
against the law
so it was just a roman reboot
you could see something like that happen
in the united states what would happen
if
you know you were from a muslim family
and you uh but over a few generations
you married into the local population
and you were kind of is you had an
islamic heritage but you were as
an american as [ __ ] apple pie well
you're going to have like an american
version
of islam you know that that could
evolve because christianity was doing
that
in the south all those southern baptist
churches
were american versions of christianity
and so is looking
so is uh mormonism it's just an american
version of christianity
well yeah i mean you kind of want
something that is going to fit in with
your lifestyle
you know if you're not in the mother
country anymore right you know and
you're living a whole different life now
well in mormonism america has put
center stage in the story and not only
america but like
in prehistoric america
they talk about that a lot in uh in
mormonism
like there were people here
in the new world you know fighting for
palestine and stuff
which is you know fighting they were
down here
fighting the uh uh what do you call them
what was that thing that they were
i don't know they were fighting the
canaanites and [ __ ] okay here here here
you know on the great plains
fighting canaanites whatever just you
know what let them play
yeah it's kind of like a funny story
this is like
yeah they're talking about old testament
[ __ ] but it's happening in america
you know i just remembered like another
little tidbit from that
uh from that mini series on netflix
where they were talking about the forger
dude's
dad and they had oh my god his parents
were so
weird like they had some video of them
from i don't know when i guess it was
like the early 80s or whatever
but it was just i don't know something
like really really creepy about them
and i guess the dad was really really
strict mormon and i guess i didn't know
that there was a lot of
i mean i figured there was probably some
crossover with uh mormons with
creationism
but i guess that the dad was
real creationist like so much so that he
saw like a kid's book with dinosaurs in
it
and he was like you know heathens you
believe in evolution so i don't know if
they like believe that dinosaurs aren't
real
or i guess they believe that dinosaurs
aren't real i mean i thought even
creationists
even your young earth creationists who
believe the earth is only six thousand
years old for [ __ ] sake
um i think eve they even crammed the
dinosaurs in there somewhere although i
think that
um i think that some of them think that
all the dinosaur fossils were put there
by god to fool everybody
like you're real hardcore creationist
young earth creationist
some young earth creationists fit the
dinosaurs in there but they only died
out like a few thousand years ago and
like humans rode around on them and
whatnot
yeah dinosaurs are all vegetarian
tyrannosaurus rex it was a vegetarian
they had those sharp teeth
but fruit bats have sharp teeth too and
they're vegetarian so yeah that's
[Laughter]
i used to be really fascinated by
creationists so i wrote i read like a
bunch of books about
i mean you don't hear as much about them
anymore i guess they're mostly staying
out of trouble i'm sure that there's
you know still a lot of creationists out
there but
i don't know there's just something
really fascinating to me about somebody
that wants to believe something so badly
now they do have old earth creationists
that are willing to concede
that the earth is the actual age that it
is because
you know obviously but you still got
you still got those young earth ones man
and it's like every single that's almost
as bad as flat earthers
i don't understand the uh the need
for things to be literally true in in
these scriptures i don't really get that
either because to me they were always
just stories
yeah and there were stories to learn
from and to teach some kind of an
example
let's teach some kind of a moral or to
have some kind of a background of some
other leader
they were more like cultural it's like a
cultural
histories that's what they were like you
know what i mean and there's something
wrong with that it's not we're not
denigrating them
yeah stories humans are storytelling
yeah animals that's what we do that's
how we impart information
yeah that's the that's the and that's
the genre of that kind of literature
yeah they're like excuse me they're like
pseudo-histories
but they were never intended to be
historical never
i mean right there in genesis no dates
are mentioned
if it had if it was intended to be
historical they would have written the
day
yeah they had dates during the time that
they were writing all that down this is
the date that jesus rode the dinosaurs
right they would have been all kinds of
games
the date on which you know noah's ark
you know [ __ ] rested on the [ __ ]
mountain after the flood they would have
given you all these dates yeah
if it was intended to be historical even
if they met made the dates up
it was never intended to be historical
ever
they're just stories yeah they're
stories to explain the past
or to explain something that you believe
in today
that they had a lot to do with it yeah
you're in a certain culture that
believes certain things so now you got
to tell a story
to explain why you believe this and
that's what they're doing
and it's a kind of a quaint
way these are the stories that you tell
around a campfire
exactly yeah you're out there in the
desert
with the bed of one which i've done that
hanging out with the bedouin [ __ ]
smoking smoking smoking shisha
which is their little [ __ ] thing and
they went to got the camels and horses
and [ __ ]
and they're just they like to party yeah
they do
don't we all they like before like the
party tell stories and [ __ ] compare
stories and [ __ ]
and uh that's that's that's where these
stories are coming from
they're they're like a campfire story
yeah and like i said just trying to make
it
like trying to squeeze it into some
things it's like this is literally true
you're just ruining it you're ruining
the story when you do that you're wrong
right yeah and like i said it's either
supposed to impart information
or like some kind of moral or something
like that because that's like an easy
way for people to remember it
they're also definitely entertainment
they're definitely entertainment
so they're movies you're watching a damn
movie
yeah they didn't hurt movies way back
then so it's like you just kind of like
you you know you're walking through the
desert or whatever and it's like you all
around the camp and everybody's like
coming up with really good stories about
[ __ ] and then they're telling stories
about legendary heroes you know
samson you know and when you look you
know
samson is kind of like a redneck version
of [ __ ]
hercules samson and hercules are
probably probably the same person strong
dude
strong dude who's the son of god kind of
a deal god's got his back
let's so you know who else is who else
is a big strong
hercules hercules francis sampson
who else um goliath
yeah um i guess you could say like
beowulf
no no no yeah i'm talking about from
that era oh from that era beowulf was
earlier yeah
yeah much later so
what they're talking about they're
probably nephilim giant
men of great renown and giants in the
earth
you know greek the greeks are saying
this
and the middle easterners are saying
this you know
that they're that gods have children
those [ __ ] are huge
they're real strong
yeah that's just a good story you know
cool story bro
well that's what i mean it just seems
like people are just making they were
just making up stories just like people
make up stories nowadays nowadays we
make
movies or you write books or whatever
they didn't really do that back then it
was just like an oral tradition but it's
no different
it's a marvel superhero yeah that's it's
actually
no difference at all i don't see any
difference samson hercules all these
guys you know it's like something out of
marvel universe
yeah and i i don't know why more people
don't and i'm not like trying to be
offensive or anything like that like
superman
definitely that's straight out of the
bible
oh yeah big time straight out of the
bible that is that god's son descended
to earth
yeah it's just he happens to be an alien
yeah but he's jewish yeah but he's
jewish yeah that's jesus
exactly what they're talking about he
space jesus yeah
well jesus was from space heaven means
[ __ ] where the stars are yeah
that's face yeah just that black piece
of paper that yeah
the earth with all the whole
it says that [ __ ] the stars actually
fall from the sky
and land on the ground and people like
look at these things
the whole [ __ ] economy of [ __ ]
bite and selling and trading the stars
that fell from the sky
man just like how much is the star worth
i mean they've been dude so i can
probably like you know
speculating on it how much would a starb
actually be worth well i'd probably pay
about ten thousand
ten thousand to norm oh yeah yeah
this whole economy of like yeah yeah
well it was just kind of like
hey was anybody selling those the same
like uh during the middle ages when they
were selling all those like pieces of
the true cross and jesus foreskins and
whatnot
yeah maniac mentioned goliath was the
other one yeah
did you say that yeah he's asking if no
i said
uh samson okay samson and um
and hercules and but samson and goliath
yeah i mentioned goliath
yeah i thought life was the one that
david killed yeah yeah
yeah it is kind of in that story
it's hinted at that goliath was a
nephilim but samson must have been a
nephilim too
really what they're doing though is uh
doc from
based upon what dr price said all these
side characters from the old testament
they're actually talking about
other canaanite gods canaan things that
canaanites believed in
before judaism
the canaanites were just other jews
that's another thing there's a lot of
misunderstanding you know what i mean
that
you know um
the early was it
the israelites you know [ __ ] they got
chosen by uh
yahweh yahweh chose israel and told them
not to worship any of those other gods
you're my team [ __ ] right and then go
out and go [ __ ]
fight the canaanites and [ __ ] they were
all canaanites
the israelites were canaanites
they were all in the land of canaan at
that time evidently
or they were calling it kanan so they
would be the same thing as you know
one christian denomination fighting
other christian denominations you know
which they did
[Laughter]
well yeah i mean that's kind of
i mean why do you think there are so
many differing sects of all these
different religions just because
one person gets a hair across the crack
of their ass about some tiny little
detail in scripture and it's like well
[ __ ] man we need to
this is so important that we need to go
off and start our whole
a whole other thing but here's the funny
thing about
genesis and exodus and all these
early parts of the [ __ ] old testament
where you have all these different
canaanites and all these different
canaanite gods and
and how israel rose to the most
prominent sect and it taking over
didn't all that was [ __ ] that's all
pseudo history
there was no war between these
canaanites they just assumed there was
there's no his there's no there's no
evidence for any of that
all right what happened was is that over
time judaism
condensed into one sect or one version
of
judaism over time they didn't kill each
other
there's no yeah but that's a lot more
exciting so you can see why that got
written
right but they're writing about this
they're writing about this [ __ ]
centuries maybe five six seven hundred
years after
yeah all that happened a long time so
they're they're just trying to write a
pseudo history to explain
how israel became that's all it is
i mean when you think about it it would
be like us writing about something that
happened in the 1500s
yeah and le as though we were there you
know i think you were there right
and that's that gets me to islam is
islam
has some damn real shaky
explanations you know what i mean where
you had muhammad and a bunch of
damn desert warriors going out and
flipping everybody and conquering all
this christian land to make
to make uh is to make a big islamic
kingdom you know there's no history
there's no proof of that
um i don't think the christian empires
of the time would have [ __ ]
tolerated that if anything what what
you're talking about
um they called it the uh the the muslims
themselves
call it the uh when they call the
islamic conquest
well that islamic conquest is only in
islamic history
nobody else has that um
west from the western point of view
islam appears out of nowhere fully
formed
so you know well everybody wants to make
themselves seem cooler
yeah you know just appeared out of
nowhere fully formed everybody wants to
make themselves seem more powerful or
more popular
or whatever what what probably what what
a lot of guys who really looked at it
and try to figure out the archaeology
behind it looking at coins and old
buildings
is that
christian kingdoms converted to islam it
was a more
it was a more um arabic
version it was arab-centric version
of chris of christianity you know what
i'm talking about
yeah because in christianity really you
know what i mean you would have been
more loyal to the [ __ ]
to um rome where the where the vatican
was
so they were going no no we're not going
to do that this is a more nationalistic
version of it no no no we're loyal to
mecca
which is a local place here and they
kind of
reinterpreted it and
there doesn't seem to be a muhammad
uh it's first mentioned
when he's first mentioned he's already
long gone
so you haven't it's a situation kind of
like the english and king arthur
they're talking about a warrior king
that used to exist
that's what they're talking about so i
don't think there ever was one
it was just a memory of one you know
well and the thing about it it's just
kind of like
better to have him in the past yeah
it's just kind of like the whole jesus
thing it's not yeah it's not like
a person like that like sort of like
that didn't exist at one point but the
you know the the memory the myth of it
the legend of it yeah
um there was never a person like that
that existed we're not saying that like
king arthur wasn't based on a real guy
or real
there was 50 or a bunch of yeah or a
bunch of dudes and they just kind of
like stuck it all together because over
the years
um you know [ __ ] gets confused right
um you know just like one like real
popular king or whatever and like this
other one and like
you know you'll start amalgamating them
together into like one
mythological figure right and i think
that's what happens a lot in these
situations yeah and this is you know
in in terms of you know when you talk
about islam you're talking about what
seventh century
it probably started off about 50 years
of fighting and they were kind of like
rebel christians and then once they take
a bunch of land
they kind of rewrite christianity and
say that yeah the land was taken by a
warrior king that
used to lead us his name was muhammad
that's what he was like they tell the
whole story
yeah it was just like anything else you
know it's
it's it's much easier to
you know all these great feats of
whatever it's easier to like just
attribute them to one person
because it was definitely whoever wrote
the quran the hadith and the sunnahs and
all that stuff
that stuff was all written in peace time
by scholars
so it wasn't written during the islamic
expansion
much later so [ __ ] you could write
anything at that point
know what i mean because you're talking
about something that happened a hundred
years ago
yeah and [ __ ] i know you rewrite history
i can't even remember what happened five
years right much less a hundred yeah
in this era you know what i mean you're
[ __ ] most people are illiterate
so they just believe what you tell them
yeah they can't check
that's true and there weren't many books
anyway so well books are really really
expensive
and like i said most people couldn't
read them yeah so it's got they were
just kind of dependent on
people that kind of tell them the
stories it gives back sometime in the um
mid 1900s maybe
some german scholars asked to see went
to mecca and asked us they were in good
with those guys
this priest that worked down here in
mecca they asked to see the oldest quran
and
they they saw it and took pictures of it
took it back to germany they didn't
recognize the language it wasn't
it wasn't islam they said it's it
read a little bit more like mutated
christianity
yeah they asked to see the book again
they wouldn't show it to them again but
they have photographs of it
so islam didn't come from islam whatever
it is
now it's it's it's totally rebooted
which means it's exactly the same as all
the other religions it's not special
well yeah product of its culture yeah
just like everything else is i mean
you know that's that's just how [ __ ]
works like i said it's not
it's not being offensive or denigrating
people's beliefs or anything like that
we're just saying that that's
that's how that [ __ ] comes about it's uh
that's how every religion's come about
muslims have the idea of kind of like
the
kind of like the way i used to think
about the the bible as a kid
that it came down from heaven it was
delivered
it was like amazon prime yeah celestial
yeah nothing further from the truth
[Laughter]
here here's the book you guys figure it
out more like compiled by
a bunch of committees over time that
disagree with each other that's really
what
yeah it's like put those out don't take
[Laughter]
the islam was kind of uh i think you
know
it was supposedly dictated to the
prophet muhammad by uh
the angel gabriel or is it michael or
gabriel i think it might have been
gibril because the gabriel that's what
they call it
so it's damn near straight from heaven
in in their mythos but not according to
the photographs
and books that complicated in that long
and it's
it's a trilogy they don't
stuff like that doesn't fall from heaven
that was that's worked on
over generations and generations of
scholars
which is pretty i mean even though
they're all me well yeah i mean
i think i read the bible when i was a
teenager probably
and you know just reading it from
an objective point of view it really
just does seem like a cobbled together
collection of stories there's no
you know it's it's obviously not really
one style it's not really one there's
stories in there that contradict one
another it's you know it's
it was compiled over a really long
period of time
and it just seems really obvious that
that's what it is
but i just realized that we didn't have
our [ __ ] party laser on
we forgot to take our electricity laser
on maybe that's why the stream hasn't
collapsed
maybe maybe maybe we have so much like
so much data
so much uh [ __ ] although i will say
that sometimes we don't usually put the
party laser on except on the longer
shows and sometimes the shorter ones
crash anyway although not as often
i don't know i don't really want to say
it's almost like now you said something
now
like it's gonna jinx it
[Laughter]
stop prop says the worst of the
jehovah's witnesses hands down
yeah they i don't know man it's like the
the first experience i have jehovah's
witnesses i don't know if i
ever mentioned this before but when i
was in sixth grade
there was a little boy in my class his
name was richard
and his parents were jehovah's witnesses
and he was like the nicest kid
but every time we celebrated a holiday
or every time you know somebody brought
cupcakes in for their birthday or
whatever
that poor little kid had to go sit in
the [ __ ] teachers lounge all by
himself
because they're not allowed to celebrate
holidays because they hate fun and joy
there's a guy uh
this guy listened to his name is hard
bastard he's [ __ ] funny he's on uh
he's on bit shoot and he just picks
certain like news articles to come up
with cnn or something they'll just pick
up a pick it apart
and then re you know show where they're
kind of lying or telling anyway
he's the next jehovah's witness and
he'll do whole shows on
on jehovah's witness what it was like
growing up in there
and basically he says that the problem
jehovah's witness is just how low
testosterone it is
just real low t the leaders just it
takes them
they're just real old people in their
80s and their 90s
they can't come to a decision on
anything and everything just moves at a
snail pace
and basically the only thing that they
can do is just like
ban you like oh that's it you're
banished
you're bad get out you're banished and
then you can't talk to that person
anymore
yeah well it's like disconnection just
like this technology yeah
that's really the only thing no one's
allowed to talk to you yeah it's just
disconnect
disconnect that's all they do but he
just said it was [ __ ]
kind of hilarious that he grew up in
that
believing what he was told you know it's
very apocalyptic
it is at the end of the world's coming
at any moment
and they've been at any moment now he
said he liked that part
he said he loved that part because they
would it was
really entertaining real lurid about
what was going to happen at the end of
the world
i think that i think largely that's why
people really like it it's like reading
it's like
yeah i think that there's like something
kind of appealing yeah
about just watching the whole world burn
yeah he said he loved that part of it
like
it's kind of like you know and it's safe
because it's fictional
yeah so i so i feel like people like
like to imagine it even though it's
[ __ ] up and it would probably
not be fun all they did was just like
you know prepare for the end of the
world
you know and that that was kind of it
was kind of exciting you felt like
at any moment the end of the world was
coming and you were ready for that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i would wonder if it made you like
appreciate your life
more than you would otherwise because
you just thought it was going to end at
any minute or would it just kind of make
you go [ __ ] it nothing matters
no i guess it would depend on the person
no they were constantly like preparing
for it
you know i mean well at least they gave
them a purpose kept them out of trouble
yeah making spiritual preparations and
they'd [ __ ] fantasize about where
they were gonna go and what was gonna
happen when all the souls go up and you
know just all
everything you know what that what it
would actually look like and
what are they gonna say on the news when
it happens so there's just you know
it was like something out of the oven
see he said he said he he said that was
the best part of that religion
i could see that uh but he said other
than that it was just kind of real culty
and you had to go to all these [ __ ]
meetings all the time and nothing would
really happen and you have to go to
people's doors and like they get all
abusive with you and stuff
no they're not abusive at all they're
real soft-spoken so no no no i mean when
you go to people's houses
oh like to and most people slam the door
on your face he didn't really talk about
terry keep saying lights lights lights
put the lights on
it was just like she just said it was he
just said it was kind of you know
boring you had to get sounded boring you
have to go to all these little meetings
and nothing happens at him
and like you said you don't get to
celebrate anyhow you don't get to
celebrate your birthday you don't
celebrate any holidays nothing why
i don't understand like why what what's
the reasoning behind that because i feel
like
they said they didn't miss that i've saw
the programs so they don't even really
miss that
they don't care about that at all
because they didn't grow up that way
i guess they didn't grow up like that so
they didn't they didn't
they didn't even really think about that
huh they said that when they got out of
the cult
the whole idea of celebrating all this
stuff so they never really got into it
even afterwards because you have to be
you have to be brought up with that to
to get
to have a nostalgia for it yeah you're
like
yeah so there's no mythology for any of
that so they don't even really
miss it still though it wasn't brought
up in them i guess
i don't know it must be really weird i
guess it's not weird for them because
like that's they don't know any
different
but like i said it's just kind of like
reading every and if you guys haven't
read
um what's her name uh david miscavige's
niece
that wrote that uh book about growing up
in scientology
it was called beyond belief i think was
called i a habit somewhere um
but that it's just strange how
no matter how weird you're like brought
up i guess it's just like [ __ ] normal
to you
yeah i mean she was brought up
to just be like a child laborer well
they have
you know jehovah witnesses uh they're
they kind of like have meetings with the
scientologists
and according to the job of witnesses
the scientologists are weird
they think scientology is a lot weirder
than them and
i don't know well i don't know
much weirder it is pretty weird yeah i
mean you know
hey my my drink's almost empty too
well polish it off well now i can't chug
that much
just you know just refill it i don't
know it's
i guess jehovah's witness isn't as weird
as scientology because they don't think
they don't have aliens do they i mean
scientology is
aliens or whatever are they they're not
really aliens galactic
overlords and dudes like demon
things and volcanoes and what i guess
that's weirder
i don't know they're all pretty weird to
me so it's kind of hard to say
i don't know but it's just i just felt
bad i felt really bad for this poor kid
i still remember
like i said it was uh sixth grade and he
always had to go sit in the other room
and i guess back in the old days like
back in the
80s yeah i guess this would have been
80s um
when it was valentine's day everybody
would make little
uh you'd make like a little mailbox and
you'd put it on the front of your desk
and then
you had to bring in valentine's for all
of your classmates and you had to have
one for everybody because they didn't
want
you know the little ugly kid like not
getting in here whatever
because that would be terrible so you
had to like buy one of those boxes with
all the
all the valentines in it and i i was
very you know diligent and i did all of
them for every single person in the
class and i made one for him too
and then when we got there like a lot of
kids had made one for him too and you
know the teacher was like no he can't
have any because
you know his religion says that he can't
celebrate the holidays and everybody in
the class was just like
well that's [ __ ] [ __ ] man it says
he can't even eat a cupcake so this is
what
i kind of wanted to ask like later on
when i worked at
when i lived in clearwater and i worked
at that scientology place
it was really weird because there were
four graphic designers
three of us uh the three girls we were
all
like agnostic or atheist there was one
guy in there and he was a jehovah's
witness
so that was why the scientologist didn't
bother him because he already had they
they were more interested in getting
people that like didn't already have a
religion that they could kind of
or they were kind of interested in like
telling he was like well you can be that
religion too but then you could just
like do scientology [ __ ] like on the
side um but he was a jehovah's witness
so they kind of left him alone
and i always wanted to ask him but i
didn't he was really nice but i didn't
want to ask him this question because i
didn't know if he'd get offended
so i'm like okay now i was like what if
just for sake of discussion what if it's
a holiday
and i bring in a box of
donuts that are you know or
cupcakes that have like um you know that
have like a little decoration sticking
out let's say it's easter and i bring
it has like a little [ __ ] bunny
rabbit sticking out of the top right
there's a little plastic one
i was like okay so you can't eat that
because it's the easter cupcake and it's
a holiday i'm blotty blah i said now
what if
i just brought in cupcakes and it was
easter
but i said that they weren't for easter
and i took the bunny out of it could you
eat it then
is it a technicality was there a
loophole can you have the cupcake if i
say that it's not
in celebration of anything if it's just
a cupcake
that's what i'd like to know so if
anybody so if anybody's a job as witness
or used to be and can answer that
question is there ways to get around the
[ __ ]
i mean obviously you can eat cupcakes
you just can't eat the cupcakes when
they're
when they're celebrating something i
guess
so it was that was just something i
always wanted to ask him but i didn't
want him to get mad what's funny is that
that's
that's not unusual that's in
christianity too
that they can't eat cupcakes that are in
celebration or something you can't eat
any meat
or any kind of food that was used as an
offering to a roman god or anything
other than a god
than your god that's that's that's the
same thing you can't eat anything that's
been sacrificed to a god
that's what they're talking about yeah
okay that kind of makes sense
right they're saying that that cupcake
was an
offering to a to a non-christian god so
you can't eat it
so technically if i just had a plain
cupcake that didn't have a plastic bunny
rabbit stuck in it
they could eat that yeah even if it was
easter but i said this isn't an easter
cupcake
this is just a regular never offered to
eat to easter it was never part of it
that's what i figured
right i figured there had to be some
kind of loophole because i said what if
i
forgot it was easter and i just brought
cupcakes because i wanted cupcakes and i
wanted you guys to have some
it's not celebration cupcakes it's just
paulie material says both
it says [ __ ] like you can't eat
things sacrificed to other gods
unless of course you know you you know
that that god
isn't real then you can eat them but if
god finds out he'll [ __ ] kill you
do you want to risk that no no
you can but you can't yeah you can't but
you can but you can't
it says you know so it's a lot of stuff
like that in there
so it's a good way if you have like a
jehovah's witness for a roommate that's
a good way to get
keep them from eating your [ __ ] is you
can just offer something well yeah you
can draw like holiday [ __ ] on you
like look i drew jacqueline it's for
halloween you can't have it sorry right
[Laughter]
just just you know oracle says that
uh it's like i figured out why uh
salamander
like for the why the white salamander
the mormons the church elders thought it
was because a salamander
was akin to a burning bush salamanders
were often thought to be able to
burn and not be consumed ridiculous i
wonder why i wonder why salamander and
people
wanted to fire but it didn't burn and
then it ran away i was like
because it was slimy sat there and just
kind of shriveled up
weird how these [ __ ] stories get
started man
i just thought that white salamander
thing i'm like that's so specific i was
like there has to be a reason behind
that
manga says more rom back in a bit yeah i
had to go get a i had to go get a new
drink too but yeah that was
i don't know that was just always
something that kind of stuck with me
because i you know like i said you know
i grew up not
not real religious and i didn't know a
lot of kids that were religious
you didn't really see it's really weird
because you didn't really see a lot of
um real overtly religious kids
i mean at least where i grew up they
didn't really talk about it or they
didn't
and you know the couple kids that we
knew that were kind of like that
everyone thought they were weirdos
you know it wasn't that people in you
know
because i went to a public school it
wasn't that the kids weren't religious
because i'm sure their families were
like but no one really talked about it
it wasn't a big thing
i feel like that only became a thing
later because when i started reading
about
all the [ __ ] that like creationists were
trying to pull
like trying to get their [ __ ] taught in
like science classes and whatnot and it
seemed like
you know a lot of the controversy came
from then but i think that was later
that seemed later
at least where i went to school it's
just wasn't something that was brought
up very much
like no one really like when we like we
learned about evolution in school nobody
bitched
no one was like taken out of class or
anything like that
like because it's against bar religion
nobody did that yeah well i think those
are issues from
from 40 years ago anyway but but like
i'm saying that's when i was in school
yeah i'm just saying i feel like it you
know it didn't happen when i was at
school and then i started hearing about
it happening like later like after i was
already out of school
you know religions don't phase me i went
to religion we went to school with all
different kinds of religions and stuff
you know what i mean like in different
kinds of christian religions
mississippi is filled with [ __ ]
pentecost pentecostal
now it's kind of like our version of
mormons i don't even know what they
believe they just like
wear funny clothes are they some of the
ones that wear like the little house and
the prairies yeah a little house on a
prairie exactly
yeah a lot yeah a lot of ones do that
yeah because i feel like
yeah they were like those long dresses
and sometimes
are they the ones with the bonnets or
who is that i don't wear bonnets i think
uh no they no they didn't wear bonnets
is that more like a quaker thing
or you know they could have cars
but all their clothes had to be uh
homemade
man who the hell's got time to do that
well i guess they the mama i guess the
mama has some
mama bear makes all the clothes and
that's exactly what she looks like and
she almost always looks like a mama bear
five five six kids makes clothes for
them all
their they pray driving out in the car
go to walmart yeah yeah yeah
man i'm really glad that i didn't end up
like that because i can't sell for [ __ ]
it's like all my kids would be walking
around looking like [ __ ]
clowns with all the [ __ ] [ __ ] i would
say
they're like look i'm just gonna drape a
sheet over you like a toga all right
little house on a prairie dresses and
stuff
but you know what i mean i always
thought it was just kind of charming
you know yeah because they're just
they're poor people
you know and they're just uh some kind
of religious people i don't even know
what they think i don't know what they
believe
well i mean honestly if you're going to
be like a religious person that's
actually really nice just
you know i don't know you just believe
what you want just keep just don't try
to force it on other people
trailing around these little kids and
little kids just wide-eyed
don't say anything yeah
wow they don't say anything they don't
have they don't have tantrums or
anything
because they know they'll get the whip
when they get home if they're bad
they'll get the switch
it might have been because they were
girls yeah girls are quieter
yeah i mean in general not always i mean
i've met some
women aren't maybe women aren't allowed
to talk
yeah that sounds about right they may
not be alive
that sounds about right right they may
not be allowed to talk unless they're
talking to their dad or
something one to a family member or
something you know because a lot of
those roles
never seen him never see him talking
yeah
a lot of those kind of old-timey
religions that are still around are very
like
attracting anybody and they don't like
women
are allowed to be preachers or yeah they
have to do what their what their band
says and
yeah what their dad says and then what
their husband says and they're not
allowed to like talk out eternal he
would get a slap
i do feel like there's still a lot of
that [ __ ] going on do they do that on
mormonism too
because i don't know if mormons i don't
know if uh women are allowed to run [ __ ]
you know what i mean like i don't know
if they're allowed to be like elders or
whatever the hell they call the art and
jehovah's witness
yeah if women can't can't run that's
what i thought and so i think mormons
are the same but it's like you know i
don't know
please correct me if i'm wrong but i'm
pretty sure that
that mormons were real patriarchal as
well
because it i don't know it just seems
like a lot of those are but we talk
about that a lot on our
cult shows i feel like a lot of dudes
you don't see a lot of women starting
cults i know it's not
zero but i feel like a lot of
men start cults just so they can
sleep with a bunch of teenage girls or
have a bunch of wives that seems to be
like at the
and so they can just like tell everybody
else what's interesting
at bottom that seems like the baby
notice that that [ __ ] kind of motivation
if you actually kind of read the history
of the of cults that are like that you
know and these are all
cults if you ask me i think pentecost is
a cult all right
it's it's it's a christian denomination
but all these denominations are cults
if you actually look at the rev the
evolution of what's going on is you have
a powerful preacher who's
looking very charismatic and everything
he kind of holds sway over an entire
community
of followers he starts ramping up his
[ __ ]
celebrity and he gets away with it
you know what i mean so then eventually
he goes oh by the way
god said that not only could i have my
wife i could have your wife too
that's how it goes well yeah all right
pretty much always yeah god says i can
have your wife
so then he does it once and then he goes
oh you know what
god says i can have your wife too that's
another one i'm taking all your [ __ ]
yeah
and then like he goes oh you know what
god just told me he says i could have
your daughter
and then he and then then then after
that he goes
and god said i have your daughter too
and your daughter
also so next thing you know he's got
seven or eight of them
because all your women's are belong to
them right because you get away with it
once and then you
you know what i mean yeah you give them
a smile and then he tries to make him
but it's always like your wife another
wife a wife oh and guess what you know
what a daughter
well yeah because then all the wives are
getting too old right yeah
[ __ ] are like pushing 28. we can't
have that well so now we need his
daughters
i think it's probably what happens is
that the first wife you got
you're asking for the one that you were
already screwing yeah you're probably
already hit
and then he says oh you know what god
says that's just cool
all right so god said that shit's cool
yeah god said
so chances are you were already hitting
that
you know what i mean that's why the
woman didn't fight it yeah you know what
i mean
so you're like well we can't go against
what you got there but the crowd up to
this concept
all right but then you start looking at
these like 16
17 year old girls right you go
i know i'm gonna hit that but her dad
[ __ ] probably will
you know won't allow it and you find one
where you got some dirt over the dad
the first one see it's always the first
time you gotta get a foot in the door
it's the guy
it's the first one so he's gotta
probably have some
some over the dad all right
and he goes for the daughter he goes
okay yeah so he gets away with it
and if he gets away with it once it's
easier all the other times
yeah because it happened with the other
guy right he's like well that guy
allowed it so it must be okay yeah
it must be part of this religion it's
okay god says it's all celestial [ __ ]
celestial marriage yeah put think about
this [ __ ] for a while
for a second right you're stealing other
people's wives and daughters
putting your dick in there and then
saying that's just from heaven yeah
that's a that's a [ __ ] and people let
you do it yeah that's a that's a hell of
a [ __ ] that's a hell of a [ __ ] con
job right there
yeah yeah i mean it's really audacious
yeah and i'm amazed anybody gets away
with it instead of like everybody just
being like [ __ ] no
i'm pretty sure though that the first
move on a wife and the first move on a
daughter
is that there's leverage yeah
yeah that would make sense right because
once you do it once like you said it's
easier to get away with yeah and again
because everyone's like you've
established
yeah you've established it you've
normalized it but the first one wasn't
normal because it was already a girl
woman you were screwing
screwing okay and you had some leverage
on the husband
so you took his wife yeah and that [ __ ]
became sanctified
after that [ __ ] was sanctified you could
now take anybody's wife
yeah because they didn't know the other
followers didn't know the background
you know what i mean i find it
fascinating how
people are allowed to get away with the
[ __ ] saying well god said this and that
and the other
and i was like isn't it funny how god
always tells you like some [ __ ] that you
wanted to do anyway yeah
but nobody really called them out on it
though right because it
i don't know it's like what they think
they're going to get like [ __ ] struck
by lightning like
you know what i mean it's like it's no
he just wanted to do that and he's using
that imagine if it was like uh
if if it wasn't just like a woman what
if it was a big pile of cocaine
and he's going to rationalize this this
is the scarface religion
yeah he's like behold before me
sits a man
that peruvian powder which is a sign
direct sign from heaven that god
wants me to snort that
i'm gonna hoover this [ __ ] up if god
didn't want me to snort this cocaine it
wouldn't be here
i definitely would not be falling upon
it
because that's how he justified [ __ ]
going after that woman you know that
she walked by and a booty was [ __ ]
walking by like that and his eyes
fell upon it and some scriptures
scripture came to mind and he goes oh
yeah that [ __ ] from heaven
[Laughter]
god's calling me yeah
well i guess that's kind of the
difference between people that
do that kind of [ __ ] it's like they see
something they want to do and then they
justify by saying well god said it was
okay
and then you get the people that are on
the other end of the spectrum that just
like
think that god told them they couldn't
do anything so they like deny themselves
and like whip themselves and whatnot
yeah i don't know uh canuck the hunter
says tom wants to be a cult leader slash
boob doctor
yeah that that's like the perfect job
for you i think i think we've uh come
upon it i'm gonna be a boob appreciate
it
he says the doctor's too much work they
show them to me after they've done
they're done and after about a month
five or six after they dropped and
everything's felt good that's a good job
[Laughter]
he's gonna have like one of those little
stickers like you know what i mean you
know how they used to like put the
little stickers like on the underwear
like the inspector or the underwear
yeah it's like yeah these past
inspections we stretched them out
i don't know why i just thought of this
i guess because you were talking about
dudes taking other people's wives or
whatever yeah every now and then when i
remember
i go and read um dan savage
i'm sure most people will know who dan
savage is but he's um kind of like a sex
columnist
um and the one that was in there today
this oh my god this one was like really
something so this guy wrote in and he
was saying that he had this
friend like a male friend he's like he's
not my best friend or anything but he's
just like a good friend
um and the friend says to him hey do you
think my wife is hot
and he's like oh this seems like a trick
question but he's like yeah you know
your wife's hot he's like would you like
to [ __ ] my wife
and he's just like again trick question
um
yeah sure that that'd be that wouldn't
be a trick for him no i'm just i know
but i'm just saying well it gets better
so um he's like so sure so this guy had
uh
you know it has a cuck fetish so he gets
off on
uh his wife banging other dudes now the
weird thing about this though is that he
doesn't want to watch
he wants them to [ __ ] and then he wants
to hear about it but not from her
she wants to hear it he wants to hear
about it from the friend
and the guy is like this is making me
really uncomfortable because after
that you're doing it he wants a second
he wants another friend too
no no he wants the dude that did it he
wants him
to call him later and tell him all about
it he's turning it off
yeah and he's like so so he's like i'm
calling the dude on the phone
and he's like and i'm talking to him
about it and he's like and the dude is
clearly
beating off and he's like it's making me
really really uncomfortable
yeah like what should i do and um
dan's like well i think even dan didn't
say this but a couple people in the
comments said
why don't you just like if you you know
because obviously first of all what
she looked like that's everyone said she
was super hot so i guess yeah okay but
um
but yeah so i had to give that dude a
good phone replay
real good phone replay so he'd invite me
back
well the guy said he'd done it like four
or five times but he's like every single
time
now i have to call this guy afterward
and he's like jerking off on the phone
while i'm trying to talk but he's like
and it's really like weird
he's like because it's like he's my
friend but he's not that good friend you
know what i'm saying
so um so some people in the in the
comments were like well
why don't you just like record yourself
yeah like talking about it and then like
send it to him and then he can beat off
at his leisure
instead of beating off while he's on the
phone with you yeah i mean that seems
like a pretty good solution
why don't you just videotape and send
the videotape i don't know he doesn't
want to see it
i guess he doesn't want to see he just
likes hearing about it that's weird
that's a very specific
because like i said a cuck fetish that's
pretty common i don't think so no i mean
it's well it's more common than you
would think is what i meant
but apparently because i i thought a lot
of like [ __ ] fetish type people like
wanted to watch it
but this guy doesn't want to watch it he
wants to hear about it but he doesn't
want to hear about it from his wife
though he wants to hear about it from
the dude you know who kind of had that
who a little bit
elvis did he in a way
elvis got to a point to where it was too
much of an effort and i think i think
maybe he had [ __ ]
you know once he started getting fat he
kind of had
self-esteem issues or something you know
what i mean
instead of going after these fans and
screwing them he would have his friends
do it
and then come back and report to him and
then tell him about how it was yeah
yeah which elvis was so much the king
he'd have other dudes [ __ ] women for him
that's the [ __ ] there you could report
back
to the came what it was like oh yeah i
don't understand i mean that's not
quite a [ __ ] fetish because that's not i
mean usually congratulations to a woman
yeah it's not your wife or your
girlfriend that you're sending out there
like [ __ ] other dudes and then you watch
it or hear about it
that's just like some women that he
thought were hot that he's like hey tell
me tell me how that went
yeah right which you know what i mean
not that that's a lot less strange i
guess
but i just thought it was like really
funny that this guy had wrote in and
being like
and everybody's like why don't you just
like record yourself talking about it
and then send it to him and then
like so you don't we got some wild ass
couples though that [ __ ]
we know this lawyer and her [ __ ]
boyfriend who's kind of like an ex-con
type dude
and uh they do all kinds of weird [ __ ]
they get these [ __ ] girls they get
these girlfriends
that live with them and they got teenage
kids too
they're probably grown now yeah she's
gotta be 18 or 19 and
or older it's just like weird [ __ ] going
on man and then there's like uh
they try to [ __ ] get us to [ __ ] do
[ __ ] with them
[Laughter]
they don't look too good i'm like nah
they're all they're always kind of on
the make
yeah they're really they're yeah
oracle said what did the wife think
about this i'm not real sure um
she seemed into it like she seemed to
like [ __ ] the friend of her husband
but i don't know how she felt about you
know he's like no i don't want to hear
it from you i want to hear it from the
other dude
maybe she was just kind of like oh well
that's his thing what are you going to
do
but that would be a little weird like
having a male friend of yours
calling you and you telling about
[ __ ] and then like having him jerking
off on the phone while you were talking
to him
that i can understand how to be a little
uncomfortable some weird [ __ ] that is
pretty weird
i mean you know i'm not [ __ ] on
anybody it's like fetish i know
i know some people have that but that
does seem like a big ask
is all i'm saying you know it just seems
like a big ass to like hey can i beat
off on the phone like while you're
talking to
that's i don't know it just seems really
weird
if you've never read dan savage's column
so that
i mean people that write it it's really
entertaining like a joint
[Laughter]
it is it's very uh incestuous well i
guess because the goth scene is not
real large in any given city
and um so you know after a time like
pretty much everybody ends up dating
everybody else
yeah that's generally how that works out
everybody knows everybody
yeah i mean at least here and most other
places i've ever been it seems like
everybody
like i said because they're not very big
so it's usually like maybe a couple
hundred
it's not personal it's just that's just
what's gonna happen when everybody knows
everybody
yeah and you know and when you get a
group of people like that that all have
similar interests
i'm sure it happens in any subculture i
mean it's like that with anything yeah
because you see all the streams and [ __ ]
too well yeah you see all the same
people
you know week to week like and you all
hang out together because y'all have
similar interests so
you know it's not that strange when you
think about it everybody's dating
everybody
yeah i mean pretty much so uh
yeah dj maniac said when i got to the
point where
where i'd walk into a club and see five
girls i [ __ ] in a circle talking to
each other it was time to leave
oh my god i'm just lucky they're not
talking about you well maybe they were
it might have been
[Laughter]
maybe not though i mean depending on how
long ago it had been
i just i don't know i feel like probably
they weren't talking about that
but everybody when when everybody walks
in the club they always think
everybody's talking about them you know
um so what uh what else you want to talk
about
i don't care how long we've been on
uh hour and 38 minutes okay so you know
not that long really not that long but
considering slow night it is a little
bit
i thought we would talk more about uh
the mormons but that didn't actually
take as long as i thought
yeah and like i said i don't really want
to ruin the miniseries for people that
want to watch it
i mean i kind of did because i said hey
all this [ __ ] was a forgery and that
dude blew himself up
but as i said he's a psycho but you do
have to like admire his commitment to
his craft and also to the fact that he
was willing to blow himself up
um to take the heat off himself
not a lot of criminals would do that um
you know not not really saying that in
an admiring way
but uh yeah dj maniac says you have any
idea how hard it is to walk out of a
room backwards in platform boots
zack says talk about scientology more
[Laughter]
oh my god what was that [ __ ] you were
telling me the other day about
um uh about tom cruise
about how he said that he'd talk to all
these world leaders and stuff oh yeah no
they have a guy all right there's a real
famous
um recording of tom cruise
and he's talking to other scientologists
they've recorded this thing and they're
going to show it to these other
scientologists
and of course they're playing the
mission impossible theme song in the
background
he's going yeah because as a
scientologist you know as a
scientologist you must know
no you you could you know like
and then the next thing you know what
the [ __ ] you talking
well they had a scientologist kind of
he's an expert in scientology
aren't we all yeah he's uh
kind of translating what [ __ ]
tom is talking about all right
there's a time where he says
and of course you know and all these
world leaders
you know and we go visit all these world
leaders and you know and
i don't remember the exact wording but
it was very carefully
worded to make it seem
to a scientologist who's listening to
this i didn't hear it at first
he said it and it just rolled right over
me like a wave of a [ __ ]
because it just sounds like corporate
jargon and [ __ ]
yeah that's what a lot of their [ __ ]
just sounds like a [ __ ] sales pitch
you know
so i wasn't really paying attention to
what he said
but this guy was going back and and
doing it line by
line and explaining what it is he's
[ __ ] talking about
and tom cruise led scientologists who
are listening this
to believe that one all of the world's
leaders
listen to tom cruise okay
because tom cruise uses
scientology
to help the world leaders solve the
world's
problems yeah and that
thereby which indicates that
scientology rules the world
yeah that's what he's saying it's like a
shadow and when
once he explained it that way i went
back i was listening because yeah that's
exactly what he's saying
tom cruise is saying yes i talk to the
world leaders
and i fix all the world's problems and i
tell them what to do
[Laughter]
because i'm using scientology i tell
them what to do
and they do what i say
all right which this means that
scientology
rules the world hmm that's some [ __ ]
there
that's exactly and and once he explained
it to me and said yeah that's what he's
telling them
well obviously they're not listening to
his advice because you know yeah
shit's not being solved just imagine tom
cruise
going to france okay and going up to the
[ __ ]
president of france i don't know if he's
prime minister or president what's that
dude's name
i can't remember offhand yeah telling
him how to deal with the [ __ ] yellow
vest protests
telling him how to deal with [ __ ] you
know an integration of islam into
society and all that kind of weird [ __ ]
you know and because tom cruise
knows scientology okay he's able to do
this
so they've told scientologists
that scientology incorporated
that it's kind of like the jedi all
right
that they're this religious organization
that are the basically the spiritual
advisors
to the world's leaders
which it makes perfect sense now when
you look at those scientology buildings
and the decorative motifs and [ __ ]
how many of them that they make and
it makes sense now
once you see all that stuff that yeah
that's the scientologists do believe
that
they think they're the [ __ ] jedi they
think they're the jedi order
you know what i mean and that they're
[ __ ] that's so cute that they are the
counselors
for the [ __ ] new republic you know
what i mean
like they're all wise and [ __ ] like how
to put in they're smarter than all of us
star wars episode one and two
yeah that's what they're talking about
i imagine that what really happened was
that tom cruise goes to all these world
leaders places and was like
knocking it's like hey can i come in and
talk to you about scientology and they
were like no
go away yeah the end
but he had to like make it seem like it
was this really well like i said he
he had like a real famous quote about it
was after
i don't remember was it after katrina or
something like that it was after some
really big disaster
and he was talking about um how
scientologists because they're the only
ones trained in scientology
tech or whatever that they were really
like the only ones that could help
people
yeah people in car accidents that's
right
yeah because of my scientology training
if i see a car accident like
in the way he said it implied that most
people
that mo and that most people wouldn't
stop and help people that had been a car
accident because most people would
yeah not just scientologists most people
would do that and their paramedics they
don't know what they're doing
paramedics don't know what they're doing
yeah they don't know that's a
scientologist to show up
and to give a [ __ ] touch assist and
like you know wave your [ __ ] hands
over some
yeah do some [ __ ] magic you got this
thing called a touch assist where they
[ __ ] touch you on the back and they
forget
and that [ __ ] keeps your [ __ ] your
feet inside your [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] or you're trying or
whatever
[Laughter]
it's [ __ ] ridiculous i mean that's i
think that's one of the most attractive
things
for people about religion is because it
makes everything like super easy
well what's [ __ ] funny is that
there's they set up those goddamn
[ __ ]
assistance tents outside of the [ __ ]
disaster zone in katrina yeah and that's
what i was thinking they had people
showing up they didn't give them water
or nothing they just [ __ ] lay them
down
and touch their backs give them a touch
assist
and they're wearing these [ __ ] orange
[ __ ]
things and these [ __ ] like dr smocks
and it says
what did it say it said on the back it
says uh volunteer minister
yeah this is on the back to make
everything look all [ __ ] i'm telling
you something right volunteer minister
if i you know spock forbid
i ever like [ __ ] went through some
horrible disaster like katrina or
something like that
and i'm [ __ ] my house got blown away
or whatever i'm laying there in a ditch
and i'm hurt and stuff
if i swear to god if a [ __ ]
scientologist comes over there and like
tries hey i'm going to give a
touch assist instead of giving me water
or a blanket or something like this i'm
going to punch him right in the [ __ ]
taint and i'm telling you that right now
and they did that [ __ ] and they handed
out leaflets and tried to get people to
[ __ ] join scientology
pay per se pay for the communication
course or something
yeah they're always on the grift man but
all that was that was so they could go
in front of their big old [ __ ] gaggle
of [ __ ] scientology donors they're
whales they give money to it
and go see we and then we do david's
mcken
david miscavige and in katrina we helped
save 20 000 people with our touch assist
people that would have died otherwise if
we hadn't come over and like
[Laughter]
crazy well like i said that's the nice
thing about what's what's attractive to
a certain kind of person like why
because it makes everything seem really
easy and really achievable i mean it's
like yeah you don't have to learn
like the hard [ __ ] like to be a
paramedic like how to help people all
you have to do is just go touch people
and it's magic and it fixes everything
what's great about the touch assist is
that it doesn't cost anything exactly
it's like thoughts and prayers like
thoughts and prayers yeah right
it's just kind of like that's the way
i'm helping you yeah it's it's
it's a way to make yourself feel better
while doing absolutely
yeah [ __ ] all you pretty much
and it's kind of the same thing at least
but i mean scientologists at least go to
the place
and like touch the people even though
they're not doing anything right
what is it okay so what do they they
just put their hand on their like that
yeah and they're doing so i guess you
could say it's kind of like acupressure
okay but it's spiritual you know like
those you know
i think i think i think acupuncture and
acupressure are spiritual too
i think a lot of that chinese medicine
is crap well yeah yeah it's just they're
making [ __ ] up
well the thing about it is that a lot of
um you know i don't want to say a lot
but there are a significant portion of
diseases and things like that where mind
over matter is a factor
so um you know if you think you know the
placebo effect is a thing
yeah if you don't have anything really
serious yeah
um and you believe that it's gonna work
then probably it will
i mean like i said obviously that's not
the case if you have something actually
physically really wrong with you
um but believing something's gonna work
does go a long way toward
like thinking it maybe will work so
maybe that kind of [ __ ] like if you do a
touch assist on another scientologist
maybe they're like oh i feel awesome
you fixed everything that was wrong with
my body just by touching me tom cruise
but
um you know for other people probably
most people would just get mad at you
especially if you
if you had just been through a [ __ ]
disaster and were like laying there all
[ __ ] up and
just wanted something to drink and a
[ __ ] snack and we're cold and your
house had been blown away and [ __ ] like
that and then you have some jackal
coming over like just touching you and
being like look i solved everything
yeah that would really really really
make me angry
i would get so so bad i'm just telling
i'm telling tom cruise right now to pull
that [ __ ] on me if i ever go through a
disaster i'm gonna hit you
i'll play amanda says she dropped
well it's st patrick's day so i guess i
mean we would have drunk anyway even it
wasn't saint patrick's day but
propaganda says they've given [ __ ]
tours and clear water piss and
miscarriage off i know i've been
watching them
yeah you were just telling me that like
yesterday or the day before
they're uh they're posting them [ __ ]
as they do it and they have [ __ ] mike
render and [ __ ] old what's his name i
kind of want to do that if it's not
expensive
mike render who is it michael that's the
one with leah remini right yeah yeah
yeah mike render
um he goes through it and [ __ ]
they talk about each one of those
buildings and [ __ ] what those
buildings are for
miscavige and scientology they just
cleared out clear water
they just started buying buildings yeah
there's like nothing there and [ __ ]
down and putting a park there there's
like a bunch of empty buildings and
parks that like
no one's kind of allowed to use them
really they didn't want logs around they
didn't want
[ __ ] people who weren't
scientologists yeah that's what they
call nine scientists
which is bad because in at least in the
uk that's like a racial slur
yeah so it used to be they just put up
these damn buildings and buy everything
and then they don't do anything with it
so you go to the downtown area and they
[ __ ] tell you to leave
yeah you know because they own
everything it's looking weird yeah it's
like let's build like all these
beautiful buildings and parks and stuff
like that and then nobody can
yeah well they used them they had
businesses they had like diners and
[ __ ] restaurants and [ __ ] they all
went out of business
i mean because it's like it's like an
island now
i remember i lived in clearwater for a
little while
in probably 2002 i think it was
um downtown clearwater still had a few
normal businesses down there
um there was a bunch but there was still
like there was a bunch of stuff that was
owned by scientologists it was still
kind of normal but um
from what i've seen lately like because
we watched like the lea rim anything
remedy thing and uh they went down there
it was like a year or two ago
and it looks like a [ __ ] ghost town
down there and i mean i don't know if it
was just because they were just like
hanging out in the park because they're
like hey it's a public park right it's
like that's why they built it and it's
downtown
and they were sitting there just like
doing nothing and talking and like cops
came like within
two minutes and told them that they had
to leave now i don't know if it's
because they recognized who they were
or because they had a camera or just
because everybody that comes down there
and said like you're not allowed to
no they explained what happened they had
they saw they saw they saw mike down
there
and they had that restraining order on
hand
that's right they sent it down to one of
those offices in that office
called the cops and the cops showed up
they gave the cops that
that that the order they said see this
order that guy right there
he's not allowed to be here yeah so the
cops went down there and says yeah you
can't be here because this is
so they made it look like scientology
controls the police
but they don't those cops didn't know
what the hell was going on until they
showed
until they saw that that uh
restraining order yeah they enforced the
restraining order which is legal
yeah because they're not allowed and
anybody that's an sp they're not allowed
to like
be within a certain scientology is
fascinating [ __ ] cult
it's a fascinating situation um
but it's not as interesting as it was 10
years ago
10 years ago it was bigger but they've
lost so many people
now it's it's it's a dead religion
it's just it's yeah now it's just a real
estate scam
that's really all it is yeah like i said
i feel like there was a lot more going
on
i mean once um you had all these high
profile
uh you know defections you know mike
rinder was like
was what he was like [ __ ] number
three yeah he was like the third
dude in charge or whatever like him
leaving like a bunch of each other in
the boardrooms and stuff
i still love that story i mean just
these guys [ __ ] beating the [ __ ] out
of each other
it's like david miscavige he's this
abusive little
short man's disease yeah but um yeah
so they're all in this board room and
that's it's like i guess it's okay for
like david miscavige to just go punch
the [ __ ] out of people
and you're not supposed to like fight
back you can't fight back
even though he's like a little sawed-off
[ __ ] yeah he plays
he weighs like buck 35. i mean seriously
that dude i could pick that dude up and
throw him come on now
it's like he's eyes and minnie me yeah
he's like he's like
my he's smaller than me yeah i think so
it's like i could probably just like
punch him in it next week
nothing yeah but uh you just have to
like sit there and take it
yeah you have to let you have to let
david's cabbage pizza [ __ ]
this thing's very intimidating you know
when you're in the church because he's
kind of like the pope it's like the pope
beating your ass
pope
he was younger when he was doing all
that i don't even think he was 50 when
he was beating up mike
no i was talking about the pope beatings
like i don't i wouldn't be intimidated
by the pope trying to beat me up either
because i'd be like [ __ ] awful
what's funny is that scientology you
know
it claims to be a religious institution
which i guess it is
um but it's also a corporation
it's selling spiritual technologies what
they call it sure
but they have the [ __ ] filthiest
mouth is no
known to man uh they say mostly what
they do is it's a long endless stream of
a stream of [ __ ]
racial slurs thank you victor [ __ ]
all different kinds of epitaphs they
call each other [ __ ] constantly they
[ __ ] they just they're
absolutely [ __ ] cruel to each other
scientologists don't play
i think that it it tends to attract
particularly the higher echelons it
tends to attract a bunch of psychopaths
yeah well because i think it rewards
psychopathy yeah to a large degree not
so much when el when lrh was still alive
um he had other problems but uh
under miscavige for sure because i think
that he kind of established he's kind of
a psychopath so i think that kind of
established the tone for everyone else
and everyone had to be like that i think
a lot of it
i think a lot of it also was
lrh was a [ __ ] naval commander so
the sea organization which is there
that's their version of the of the of
the clergy
of the priesthood was modeled after
navy yeah it had a navy flavor to it
it's kind of paramilitary navy flavor
yeah and old school
paramilitary stuff like when i was in
the army it was a constant stream of
[ __ ] filth
coming out of your mouth god's stream of
filth just was just the culture
and lots and lots of slurs
but it was just it was mostly for fun
because you're talking to france you
know what i mean
it's it's not like it's not
mean-spirited
well it's not like you're going up to
like a random stranger and like
you know it's calling them names and so
because why would you do that one unless
you're a total [ __ ] so i think it
might have started out the same way with
the c
in the sea org but david miscavige was
[ __ ] mean
he took that general motif
of a paramilitary organization and
wrapped it way up
there's nothing paramilitary or military
about david miscavige
he's never been in the military although
there are ex-military and ex-law
enforcement guys in
the sea org but the guys that run it
have never been in it
but um which i think was part of the
attraction of why
tom cruise went um
tom cruise was just an actor you know
i can say he's just an actor yeah um
he made a job he made an entire living a
very successful one pretending
pretending to be fighter pilots and
pretending to be this and that
and pretending to be heroic
but he never had the chance of [ __ ]
going into the military or really be
really to really be the kind of person
that he pretends to be
you know you can't he couldn't do that
but tom cruise gonna join the [ __ ]
army rangers
it's just not gonna happen well
scientology gave that to him gave him
the opportunity of some training and
discipline and being in a part of a
military style organization it's not
military
it's like the real military but it it
has a lot of elements of that
so in a way i think
and like i said i don't like talking
[ __ ] about tom cruise i tom cruise you
know what i mean i
actually respect his respect his game
um and i think when it came to
scientology tom cruise probably got the
best
possible scientology experience a person
could ever get
because they really bent over backwards
oh yeah they kiss his ass big time doing
all kinds of [ __ ] for tom
all right um tom as an actor does a lot
of [ __ ] that other actors wouldn't do
he really can't fly aircraft at
helicopters he can ride air he can
he can ride motorcycles he can shoot
guns he's pretty good
so he's not a fake
he really does have some skills but he
is an actor
yeah you know he's an actor he's an
artist
um scientology gave him i think
personal credibility yeah that he felt
like he was lacking
that he felt he was lacking which is
dumb because it's just kind of like
he could have done it without it canoe
reeves did kenny reeves
[ __ ] badass yeah and well the thing
about it is like there's nothing
um you know inherently bad about being
an actor it's like
you know it's just another job like any
other job it's one that you're good at
it's like
i couldn't do it yeah um that's not
enough for tom though
well that's what i'm saying that's his
issue right that's not an issue with
acting in general well a lot of actors
are
losers so he you know um i understand
where he's coming a lot of actors are
just losers
he wanted to be more than that you know
which
he had a lot of ambitions and i think
scientology gave him a lot of ambition
we're going to make you a world star
real good but
you're a secret agent you're actually
going to be a world leader
that's what they were [ __ ] trying
you're going to tell all the
i can see that he doesn't believe that
but he's trying to get
other scientologists believe that yeah
did you say thank you to victor
and uh did you see that he said
that's a bad that's a bad issue i
haven't worn this in a really long time
um somebody else asked about it too like
stop prop said where'd you get that
shirt
i don't i got it a long time ago at a
horror convention
and i can't remember what the name of
the booth was that but they had all
their
merchandise was all like hp lovecraft
themed shirts and they were all
like hp lovecraft like liquor
um you know labels so i got this one
and i got the one the other one like the
dunwich one like the the brown one that
i wear sometimes
uh but yeah i got both of these but i
just haven't worn this one in a really
long time for whatever reason because i
think i forgot
it was like hanging in a different part
of my closet and i forgot it was in
there so i just saw it today
victor said that tom cruise is a power
bottom that'd be funny
i could see that that'd be [ __ ] funny
if tom cruise jumping off that bike
[ __ ] landing down on a big old fire
hydrant style dick just ass first just
hitting and then go boom
and just on miss david stick
like that yeah he's doing the whole
thing he's twerking it's working
he's working on a big old [ __ ] thanks
i really wanted to picture tom cruise
twerking
tom cruise twerking thanks for that all
oiled up and twerking
damn it like cardi b
yeah and now and also you just made me
[ __ ] picture
tom cruise and david miscavige both
oiled up and twerking
like butt to butt so
again thanks for that i didn't really
hey and i like gay porn okay but it's
just kind of like
[ __ ] [ __ ] man not those two [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we're gonna get in such trouble we're
gonna it's like somebody's gonna sue us
david miscavige is gonna come beat us up
or he's gonna try to beat us up he's
gonna like he's gonna knock on the
on the bottom of the door because he's
so small and then he's gonna open the
door and he's gonna what
[Laughter]
zach jumping i can imagine people want
to see tom cruise
i'm sure there are i'm not among them
but um you know i don't know
i can't really think of anybody i don't
know if i'd really want to see anybody
twerking it's it's not a real
it's not a real flattering it's not a
good look
i don't know maybe that's just me that's
just you
[Laughter]
i don't know well no i don't know i
don't know i i just can't really think
of anybody right now that i've got to
teach you that's working we'll put that
[ __ ] on phone
put that [ __ ] on the show it's not that
hard okay i mean twerking
it's not like something that really has
to be taught i feel like i think it does
looks like a complicated [ __ ]
complicated dance move jenny
i feel like it's really not
[Laughter]
amanda says i typically only day drink
on holidays but you know well
you know stop prop says it's hard to
find lovecraft shirts
it is kind of even the ones that i've
seen because some people make them on
etsy and stuff like that
but a lot of them are not that cool
you know what i mean i don't know it's
like a lot of them i didn't really like
the designs
that's why i liked this particular i
wish i could remember because it's been
[ __ ] it was probably like 10 years
ago
that i uh found it but it was just like
a booth that was at
uh you know the the horror convention
that we went to
what the [ __ ] the name of it i can't
remember but it used to be called scream
fest
when i went a long time ago and like i
said it's probably 10 or 11 years at
this point
but there was a whole booth there and
they had like a whole bunch of shirts
and they had a whole line of these
and most of them were really cool so it
was like really really hard for me to
like just pick two out
but you know i got that uh
pizza dough going right do you yeah
i figure i'd put that stone inside the
damn grill outside
and [ __ ] do pizza outside on the
grill outside pizza
what tonight or tomorrow tonight okay
yeah you want one
yeah later what time you've got sauce
and everything's almost said
okay yeah i got sauce and everything
i'll even like uh dude um
i know you don't like pizza i'll put the
slice up so that uh
georgia sausage and put on there sound
good
oh no i got i got i got um i forgot
i got uh mushrooms yeah can i have one
with just like mushrooms and peppers
i don't need i don't need meat yeah okay
i can do that because like i said a lot
of times i like those sausages but
you know heartburn okay
i know but i still get heartburn from
sausage-y kind of meat
well don't let you know take it up with
my digestive system i don't know
what to tell you um i i don't like it
either
but uh you know bridgette says hey guys
can you still make the old shirts it was
one of your older designs
some of them we still have um we still
have the screens for
most of them i think i think i don't
know what it depends on what she wants
yeah it depends on which one the only
little picture of me and jenny i have
that one still yeah i think the only one
that we don't have a screen for still
is the friday the 13th looking one
but i still have the artwork for that so
i could burn another screen
if i really needed to because actually i
kind of like that shirt i wouldn't find
another one
because i have one and it's like it's
kind of worn out but uh i think we've
made we
cannibalized that screen another batch
of those got us mail them out
yeah i know i just like i said i sent
one out to uh
xanada cause he sent me some money like
on one of the last streams so i sent him
a shirt out the other day so hopefully
he would have got it i don't know if he
would have got it by now i was going to
vegas
but uh yeah bridget said it was one of
the girls ones
yeah if you let me know which one it is
like we have most of the screens like i
said i think the friday the 13th one i
don't have that screen anymore but i
could burn another screen for it if i
had to but it was one of the girl
what girl one of the girl
there's one with jenny on it with me and
jenny yeah little bitty one
the girl was jenny i can't even remember
like the boobs
the girl the girl with the boobs that's
me
yeah but you know she said she's trying
to find it good so we'll figure it out
because i i don't even remember like all
the ones we've done over the years
because i have some that i made for
zazzle
yeah she says you had it in your older
promo so it actually might be
maybe it's a zazzle one then i don't
really know because we only started
yeah we had some sad ones we had some
well i still have them
i still have them up there those ones
are like full color
but the ones we because we only started
doing the um
the screen printed ones fairly recently
and those are usually just one color
they're white you look like you're
wandering off and yeah fading and yeah
we've been doing the show for almost two
hours
yeah a little over two hours two hours
and seven minutes
wait are you ready to lick i'm about
ready you ready to call in at night
you call it a night
four times yeah yeah yeah about ready to
call tonight
yeah should i just looked on zazzle i
didn't see it if you can like let me
know which one it was i'll find it for
you and we'll figure it out
zach says the girl with the giant boobs
by steve larsen
the girl with the dragon tattoo yeah
that that'll be the fourth book in the
series
uh you know or actually they did one
didn't they because we saw like the girl
in the spider's web
didn't we see if we saw the theater
right no which one yeah yeah
the girl in the spider's web when that
before although steve larsen's dead
isn't he
the the author picture says how's the
friday night slot working out i haven't
been able to make it so far it seems to
be working good
um we get most of the same people
turning up and uh
you know it's been kind of nice having
saturday nights free
we went out to mannequins not this past
saturday but the one before that this
past saturday we actually didn't go out
because we went out monday night instead
because monday night was our monthly
goth night momentum worry
and i was like man i don't want to go
out saturday night and monday night too
it's like my liver will never forgive me
um yeah stop prop says go make jenny
some pizza
[Laughter]
i will i wouldn't honestly it's peppers
would be good but
even if it's just mushroom is good too
okay like i said i'm not a big fan of
real meaty pizzas i like this mushroom
is easier
yeah just mushroom would actually be
fine i totally forgot that you had
bought mushrooms at the yeah got a bunch
of them to use up
[ __ ] yeah man put a bunch of mushrooms
on there yeah victor says i'm gonna
literally set an alarm so i can try to
catch it yeah it's
i mean it's it's kind of fun for us to
do on friday night i i was kind of
worried about moving it
because i thought everyone would be like
oh [ __ ] now we can't watch it but it
seemed like most of the same people
turned up
and um we started an hour later like 6
p.m
so people could kind of get home from
work and do whatever like when we're
watching it but seems to be working out
okay
you know
he's just like what he doesn't care
anymore all right so
he's not even talking nightmare no no
what's your opinion i gotta do
zack says what's your opinion of
hawaiian pizza though i love it i
actually love hawaiian pizza it's not my
favorite
but i know a lot of people have really
really strong feelings about it
but they have strong feelings about well
some people really really think
pineapple does not belong on pizza oh i
really i like it
it's like i said it's not my favorite
but if somebody says hey you want a
hawaiian pizza i'm not gonna say no [ __ ]
that you can put anything on pizza
pretty much see the [ __ ] crap they're
putting on japanese pizza
[ __ ] octopus ink instead of [ __ ]
tomato sauce just crazy [ __ ] yeah i mean
put a little bit of
pineapple on there a little bit of
sweetness to kind of offset this
the saltiness of of ham of the ham yeah
well that's why it works really well is
because it's a sweet and salty yeah
uh kind of thing and you know it's it's
the same kind of [ __ ] that well
they have that in hawaii a lot too where
you have like this spicy ham sandwich
there's a pineapple on there because
it's a nice cabbage
that's yankees that are scared of that
kind of [ __ ] don't worry about them
you know what you know what's really
weird when i was in the uk
i saw some frozen pizzas in the grocery
store and they had
uh corn kernels on there yeah not good
and i thought that was pretty weird yeah
um south america but ever so well
and ever since that it's apparently it's
a big thing in japan too yeah
like they put kernel corn on there south
americans also put [ __ ] green peas on
there
that's great why would you do that great
and check i mean he's
just [ __ ] crazy like i said it's you
know whatever it's just kind of like
whatever's kind of around
don't do it but if you think if you
think
putting pineapple on pizza is [ __ ]
crazy then you just haven't been around
you know yeah because some places they
put some really weird
but yeah i don't have a problem with the
pineapple on pizza not at all
all right so we're gonna go make a pizza
yeah on the grill
and we will be back on friday night
we're gonna talk about
the disappearance of the sodder children
a very mysterious case happened back in
the 1940s
i wrote about it in my book and it's
kind of like a well-known mystery
but that was one everybody voted for
this week so that's we're going to be
talking about on friday night at 6 p.m
eastern standard time
so we will see you guys then and as
always
thank you for dropping by thank you
everybody that donated
and we'll see you on friday evening bye